a new health care bill passed by the
house last week still causing still
causing a lot of controversy and booing
in this crowd a lot of people are
unhappy that the bill allows employers
to deny employees coverage based on
certain pre-existing conditions now
there's a long list of pre-existing
conditions that can cause someone to be
denied coverage for example there's the
usual things like sleep apnea and
diabetes those are two of them but if
you look further down the list on this
new bill some of the work conditions get
a little more interesting for example
there's this one-week handshake that one
yeah having a case of the Mondays not
look at this
getting Joey in a which friend character
are you quit that's a pre-existing
condition yeah this one having a Chinese
symbol tattoo when you're not Asian
three more searches on Craigslist for a
cool hammock and you're legally
downloading an Ed Sheeran album making
prolonged eye contact with someone as
you slowly wiped down the gym equipment
[Applause]
having Bing as your default search
engine in ability and ability to sustain
erection unless constantly hearing the
t-mobile ringtone
[Applause]
telling someone you're totes caught up
on The Bachelor okay apparently we do a
volume business here they're not all
great and finally blow-drying your
testicles in the men's locker room with
your earbuds in
[Applause]
you